[Musique]
soudain je suis devenu complètement ta bouche
mais les charmes modernes et ceux-là oui oui oui
il suffit d'aller du coin des acacias et d'avoir
tu es à 1000 kilomètres et tu fais quelque chose d'impossible
hammam sauna ou au sens figuré il y a quelque chose
doit convenir à votre peau et à votre objectif, nous voulons
Je vais aussi un rouge terne et des rencontres
je ne suis pas ici avec toi depuis des années
autorisé à vivre dans une maison
je n'avais plus besoin de me déposer
prestashop ils sont ici
autour de la souris, posez un défi
[Musique]
dans un procès pour t'obtenir ça
techniques de construction, je veux dire la fin
tu reviens là-bas pour rencontrer un
bidon expérience c'est ça qu'on bombarde
bon labo non non, je vais aussi emballer
ajoute que nous commençons par le maquillage
les deux marquent parce que j'imite qu'ils étaient
vraiment beaucoup d'émotion bordbar
Ariostea pourrait-elle vous heurter en moto familiale
nuances et famille à également sur ou dans ceux
grosse commande de Gran Canaria Jack maintenant
tu sais, donc le sien est passé par là
c'est beau comme c'est beau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qui l'a acheté
Josh pour un oreiller sous sa barbe
sabot préféré à envelopper
[Musique]